wenn Hand schon Yang mit seinem Boot zum
Fischen rausfährt überlegt er nicht nur
wo der beste Fang zu erwarten ist
sondern auch wie gefährlich sein
Arbeitstag werden könnte
in letzter Zeit gibt es wieder häufiger
Militärübungen wenn es keine
Schießübungen gibt dürfen wir hier
eigentlich rumfahren
heute ist das Gebiet um diese kleine
Insel tabu denn es wird scharf
geschossen und das taimanesische Militär
will vorbereitet sein auf einen
möglichen chinesischen Angriff
näher ran darf huangs Fischerboot nicht
denn die Soldaten schießen auf Schiffe
die sie dafür extra aufgestellt haben
normalerweise üben sie da drüben
heute hier guck mal dort sie haben
getroffen
auf Kim men einer Inselgruppe die zu
Taiwan gehört aber nur zwei Kilometer
vor der Küste von China liegt ist die
Angst vor einer neuen Eskalation
allgegenwärtig
Thomsen Po kann Chinas Festland vom
Strand Aussehen
abwehrbarrieren Bunker und Panzer sie
erinnern daran dass nirgendwo so lange
um die Grenze zwischen China und Taiwan
gerungen wurde wie hier
für ihn ist die Erinnerung daran total
präsent er stammt auch aus einer
Fischerfamilie ist hier aufgewachsen
als ich ein Kind war konnte ich das
Gebiet hier nicht einmal betreten da
alles entlang der Küste von kinnman
vollständig unter militärischer
Kontrolle stand
damals brauchte man einen strandschein
um ins Meer gehen zu können
das Militär musste eine Genehmigung
ausstellen
er hat Angst dass auf Kind nennen wieder
gekämpft werden könnte deshalb setzt er
sich heute als Politiker dafür ein dass
die Spuren der jahrzehntelangen Gefechte
erhalten bleiben als Mahnmal und als
Zeichen dafür dass die Bedrohung immer
noch akut ist so wie der riesige
Lautsprecher wenn China
Artilleriegranaten herüberschoss statt
mit Sprengstoff auch mal mit
kommunistischen propaganda-flyern
gefüllt antwortete Taiwan mit
lautstarker Gegenpropaganda
Tongs & Co macht sich Sorgen denn die
Situation zwischen den beiden Ländern
ist so angespannt wie lange nicht bei
einem Angriff Chinas wäre kinman das
erste Ziel nein dann wird dieser Tag der
Beginn eines umfassenden Krieges sein
denn ich glaube wenn Festland China
einen siegering will dann will es einen
umfassenden siegerring und nicht nur die
kleinen Inseln penku pimen oder Matsu
einnehmen
die Kommunistische Partei betrachtet das
demokratische Taiwan als Teil von China
seit Jahren will sie Fakten schaffen und
der chinesische Präsident hygienping hat
es zu seinem persönlichen Ziel erklärt
das Land wie er es nennt zu vereinen
Amerika will das verhindern US-Präsident
Joe Biden geht einen Schritt weiter als
seine Vorgänger und zieht eine rote
Linie bei einem Angriff Chinas würden
US-Soldaten Taiwan zur Seite stehen
die Politik war eigentlich immer darauf
abgestellt dass die USA versichert haben
dass sie sich offen halten würden wie
sie in einem Konfliktfall zwischen China
und taiwand reagieren würden
auch wenn die USA versichern dass ich am
Grundsatz nichts geändert hätte reagiert
das Außenministerium in Peking scharf
beides Äußerungen sei ein schwerer
Verstoß gegen die bisherige Vereinbarung
niemand solle Pekings Entschlossenheit
unterschätzen
nicht nur verbal spitzt sich der
Konflikt zu China demonstriert Stärke
mit militärmanövern und auch mit Drohnen
die vom Festland bis nach kinnmans
fliegen
Chinas Propaganda will Taiwans Militär
lächerlich machen viele spotten über die
Soldaten die versuchen eine Drohne mit
Steinen vom Himmel zu holen
das sind alles kleine Nadelstiche die
dafür sorgen sollen den Druck permanent
aufrecht zu erhalten und so immer das
Gefühl in Taiwan zu verbreiten noch
gegen den über den USA das hier sehr
viel Druck in der Situation ist und dass
die Volksrepublik gewählt ist unter
allen Umständen ein irgendwie geartete
Loslösung Taiwans von vom Festland zu
verhindern
auf den Mensch schmiedet Wut santum die
militärische Vergangenheit seiner Insel
um aus den artilleriegeschossen von
damals macht der Küchenmesser und
Werkzeuge die Überbleibsel sind auch
eine Warnung dass die Bedrohung immer
noch aktuell ist
seit meiner Geburt habe ich hier den
Krieg erlebt
bis ich 20 war
von 1958 bis 1978 als die ganze Zeit
diese Geschosse zu uns geflogen sind
wenn Du das nicht selbst erlebt hast
kannst du diese Angst nicht
nachvollziehen
schon als Kind half der heute 64-Jährige
im Familienbetrieb mit der Vorrat an
geschossen reicht noch für viele viele
Jahre bei jeder Baustelle auf der Insel
kommen neue zum Vorschein früher
verdienten sich die Kinder damit ein
Taschengeld
das Leben früher auf Kimmen beahmt und
hart
wenn die Kinder Bonbons oder Eis wollten
konnten sie nicht wie heute einfach nach
Geld fragen
er will auf keinen Fall dass es auf
kinnman noch einmal so weit kommt der
lodernde Konflikt macht vielen Angst
bei Fischer funkt schon young rund um
die Insel ist es ruhig geworden vorerst
auch er hofft dass der Frieden hält
was wir uns wünschen ist Frieden und
unsere Souveränität zu behalten wir
denken auch nicht darüber nach ob ein
Krieg gut oder schlecht ist wir wollen
genug zu essen haben und gut schlafen
können
zum satt werden reicht der Fang von
heute nicht dieser hier ist so klein
dass der Fischer ihm seine Freiheit
schenkt die wünscht er sich auch für
Kinder auf der die Erinnerung an den
Konflikt zwischen China und Taiwan
allgegenwärtig ist und wo deutlich wird
wie schnell die Vergangenheit wieder
Realität werden kann
[Musik]